D
WE'RE GOING TO CRUSH THEM, AND
HE UNLEASHED THE MILITARY, AND
WE DID IN A MATTER OF MONTHS.
WITH THE RIGHT POLICY AND THE
RIGHT LEADERSHIP, THINGS CAN
CHANGE VERY, VERY QUICKLY.
PEOPLE EXPERIENCED THAT WITH
DONALD TRUMP AND THEN THE
FLIPSIDE OF IT WITH JOE BIDEN
WHICH IS EXACTLY WHY THEY'RE
POINTING THE FINGER IN THE CHEST
OF DEMOCRATS.
WILL: WE'VE TALKED ABOUT HOW
UNPOPULAR MANY OF THE ACTUAL
IDEAS OF DEMOCRATS, GENDER
ISSUES, SHUTTING DOWN COAL
PLANTS, OPEN BORDERS, LIKE, PUT
ON A BLANK BALLOT FOR MOST OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO SAY HOW
DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THESE
POLICIES, HELD GARNER MINIMAL
SUPPORT.
SO IN ALTERNATIVE WHAT DEMOCRATS
HAVE FOCUSED ON IS DEMOCRACY,
ONE OF THOSE IS VOTER
SUPPRESSION.
THAT'S BEEN FORWARDED BY STACEY
ABRAMS, FOR EXAMPLE, IN GEORGIA
FOR QUITE SOME TIME.
BY THE WAY, HERE'S EARLY VOTING
TURN THEOUT IN GEORGIA, 2.2
MILLION, WHICH I BELIEVE IS A
RECORD.
PETE: 2.2 MILLION SUPPRESSED
VOTERS.
RACHEL: YEAH.
BY THE WAY, I HATE EARLY VOTING.
I REALLY WISH WE HAD A HOLIDAY
FOR THAT.
I GET YOUR POINT NOW.
WILL: IT'S IN THE FACE OF
SUPPOSED THREAT TO DEMOCRACY,
VOTER SUPPRESSION.
RACHEL: RIGHT.
WILL: AND THEN, OF COURSE, ONE
WOULD SAY HOW DOES SAVES CITY
ABRAMS RESPOND TO THAT?
>> LET'S BE CLEAR, THE FALSE
NARRATIVE THAT VOTER TURNOUT
DISPELS THE IDEA OF SOCIETIER
SUPPRESSION MISUNDERSTANDS THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF SUPPRESSION.
IT'S ABOUT CLOCKING THE RAFTERYE
ARTERIES OF THE PROCESS AND
STOPPING CERTAIN VOTERS.
WHILE THE POLLS ARE ALWAYS GOING
TO TELL THE STORY YOU WANT TO
SEE, WHAT WE KNOW IS THE UNTOLD
STORY IS THAT THIS IS A TIGHT
RACE, NECK AND NECK, AND WE
BELIEVE WE ARE ON A PATH TO
VICTORY IF WE CAN GET ALL OF OUR
VOTERS TURNED OUT AND IF THEY
CAN NAVIGATE THE DIFFICULTIES
PUT IN PLACE.
PETE: HERE TO HELP US TRANSLATE
IS FOX NEWS ANCHOR AND OUR
FRIEND, SHANNON BREAM.
WELCOME.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU GUYS.
PETE: I KNOW YOU'VE GOT A LOT OF
BIG STUFF COMING UP, YOUR GOING
TO BE A BUSY WOMAN.
>> WE DO.
PETE: WE'LL BE WATCHING.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF --
>> WELL, OKAY, BECAUSE I KNEW WE
WERE GOING TO DISCUSS THIS.
WE HAD HER ON "FOX NEWS SUNDAY"
A FEW WEEKS AGO, AND IN THIS HAD
JUST HAPPENED, ALL OF OUR
FOUR-YEAR LEGAL BATTLE ABOUT
THESE CLAIMS OF WHAT'S GOING ON
IN GEORGIA, THE JUDGE SAID FAIR
FIGHT ACTION DID NOT PROVIDE
DIRECT EVIDENCE OF A VOTER WHO
WAS UNABLE TO VOTE, EXPERIENCED
LONGER WAIT TIMES OR WAS
CONFUSED ABOUT VOTER
REGISTRATION STATUS.
THAT'S WHAT THE JUDGE SAID --
PETE: FAIR FIGHT ACTION IS --
>> THAT'S HER GROUP.
SHE WANTS TO TAKE IT UP WITH
THAT JUDGE, HE SAID THERE WAS
NOTHING THAT HE FOUND, THAT
NOBODY COULD ACTUALLY SAY I
TRIED TO GO VOTE, I TRIED TO
REGISTER, AND I COULDN'T MAKE IT
HAPPEN BECAUSE OF GEORGIA'S LAW.
WILL: AND INCREASED EARLY VOTING
TURNOUT --
>> IT'S ASTRONOMICAL.
WILL: IT SEEMS ALMOST
CONSPIRATORIAL.
>> I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT --
[LAUGHTER]
BUT I DO KNOW A FRIEND OF MINE,
SHE WORE ORANGE IN THIS VIDEO ON
THE TODAY THAT THE DOGS WERE
PLAYING TENNESSEE, IS SO MY
FRIEND'S BIGGEST UPSET WAS THE
CHOICE OF OUTFIT TO MAKE THESE
COMMENTS ON GAME DAY.
RACHEL: IS THERE ANY BACKLASH
FOR HER SAYING THESE THINGS?
I MEAN, THEY'RE JUST SO
DEMONSTRABLY FALSE.
WILL: IT'LL BE FLAGGED AS
MISINFORMATION, I'M SURE.
RACHEL: RIGHT.
>> WELL, AGAIN, SHE CAN GO
AGAINST THIS JUDGE WHO IS
CLEARLY NOT A TRUMP APPOINTEE,
SOMEBODY WHO LOOKED AT THIS FOR
FOUR YEARS, SO IT'S THE PUBLIC
THAT'S GOING TO MAKE THE
DECISION.
AND I THINK MANY OF THEM HAVE
LOOKED AT THIS AND SAID SHE'S
GOING TO LOSE BY A WIDER MARGIN
THIS TIME AROUND THAN LAST TIME
AROUND WITH GOVERNOR KEMP --
RACHEL: AND THERE WERE SOME
PROMINENT DEMOCRATS IN GEORGIA
WHO ARE NOW SAYING WE'RE GOING
TO VOTE FOR KEMP.
PETE: SO YOU'RE SAYING STACEY
ABRAMS WORE ORANGE IN AN AD --
>> IN AN INTERVIEW, RIGHT.
MY COLLEGE FOOTBALL FAN FRIENDS
WERE MORE UPSET ABOUT THAT --
PETE: IT'S A BIG DEAL.
[LAUGHTER]
SO MAYBE SHE IS JUST A BAD
CANDIDATE, AND THE VOTERS
CONCERN.
>> WELL, THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE
WHO THINK HER CAMPAIGN ITSELF
HAS NOT BEEN STELLAR, AND SHE
HAS SOME PROBLEMS LIKE ALL
CANDIDATES DO, BUT SHE'S CLEARLY
NOT CONNECTING THERE IN GEORGIA.
PETE: HERSCHEL WALKER IS
FEATURED IN THE PREGAME
VIDEOS --
WILL: STAR FOR THE GEORGIA
BULLDOGS.
PETE: BECAUSE, OF COURSE, YOU
CAN'T THINK GEORGIA FOOTBALL
WITHOUT HERSCHEL WALKER, AND
SHE'S WEARING ORANGE.
WILL: SO, SHANNON, LET'S STAY ON
GUBERNATORIAL RACES AND LOOKING
FORWARD TO WHAT MAY HAPPEN ON
TUESDAY.
YOU LOOK AT STACEY ABRAMS, AND
SHE COULD LOSE YET AGAIN.
YOU LOOK AT BETO THE BETO TO TO
ROARKE IN TEXAS, AND IT LOOKS
LIKE HE'LL CONTINUE TO LOSE
AGAIN, CAN CONTINUOUS LOSERS
CONTINUE TO BE THE STARS OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY?
>> I DON'T KNOW IF YOU READ THE
PIECE IN THE ATLANTIC THAT TALK
TALKED ABOUT THIS, BUT THEY'RE
CALLING THEM SUPERSTAR LOSERS.
[LAUGHTER]
THEY GET PEOPLE OUT AND THEY GET
A LOT OF STAR THE POWER AND THAT
KIND OF THING, BUT WHEN IT COMES
TO CLOSING THE DEAL WITH VOTERS
AT THE BALLOT BOX, THAT'S NOT
THEIR STRENGTH.
THEY CONTINUE TO BE STARS.
YOU CAN GO BACK AND AND TICK
THROUGH ALL OF THE CAMPAIGNS
THAT BETO'S HAD, HE'S LOST JUST
ABOUT EVERYTHING THAT HE'S RUN
FOR.
RACHEL: HE SEEMS TO BE REALLY
POPULAR WITH THE ELITE DONOR
BASE, AND WHEN IT GETS TO THE
BALLOT BOX, THEY DON'T MAKE IT.
I CAN NEVER FORGET THE PICTURE
OF STACEY ABRAMS SITTING, YOU
KNOW, CRISSCROSS ON THE FLOOR OF
A CLASSROOM UNMASKED WITH ALL
THESE BEAUTIFUL CHILDREN WITH
THEIR SMILES ALL A MASKED AND,
AGAIN, POINTING TO WHAT A BAD
POLITICAL CANDIDATE SHE IS, JUST
NOT REALLY -- AND THIS WAS AT A
POINT WHERE PARENTS WERE ALREADY
SAYING ENOUGH WITH THE MASKS.
IT'S JUST OUT OF TOUCH.
>> SHE DEFINITELY DRIVES A
CERTAIN PART OF HER PARTY, BUT
CAN YOU REACH BEYOND THAT TO THE
INDEPENDENT AND SWING VOTERS.
RACHEL: THAT'S RIGHT.
>> THAT'S WHERE IT'S MORE
DIFFICULT BECAUSE SHE'S SO
PROGRESSIVE.
PETE: ANY PREDICTIONS ON
ELECTION NIGHT?
>> MY STOMACH HURTS THINKING
ABOUT THIS.
BUT YOU GUYS LOVE IT, RIGHT?
WE KNOW WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
WAIT ON PENNSYLVANIA.
THE SECRETARY OF STATE HAS BEEN
WARNING US IT'S GOING TO TAKE
DAYS, AND I THINK IF WE KNEW
THAT NIGHT THERE WAS A BLOWOUT,
I THINK IT WOULD GIVE US A
PICTURE ABOUT THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY.
BUT NEW HAMPSHIRE'S GOING TO BE
EARLY TOO, AND IF BY ANY STRETCH
THE REPUBLICANS PULL THAT OFF, I
THINK THAT WOULD SIGNAL GOOD
NEWS --
WILL: DO YOU THINK GEORGIA WILL
BE THE ONLY ONE WE HAVE TO WAIT
ON?
>> WELL, GEORGIA HAS A RUNOFF,
THEN THAT TAKES US TO DECEMBER
6TH.
SO WE COULD WAIT WEEKS --
PETE: WHO'S ON YOUR SHOW?
>> WE HAVE OKLAHOMA GOVERNOR
KEVIN STITT, HE'S A REPUBLICAN.
THIS IS THE DEEPEST OF RED
STATES.
WHY IS HE IN SUCH OF A TOUGH
BATTLE THERE?
AND CONGRESSMAN JIM CLYBURN
FRESH OFF HIS COMMENTS LIKENING
WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW TO THE RISE
OF HITLER IN THE 1930s.
WE'RE GOING TO ASK HIM TO
EXPLAIN THAT.
PETE: THAT WILL BE AN
INTERESTING INTERVIEW.
>> IT IS.
WILL: I WOULD LO TO HEAR THAT
ANSWER.
THREAT TO DEMOCRACY, EXPLAIN.
>> YEAH.
YOU CAN WATCH IT ON "FOX NEWS
SUNDAY."
PETE: WE WILL.
RACHEL: THIS IS, LIKE, THE BEST
TEASER EVER.
>> CONTINUE ENJOYING THIS SHOW,
AND LATER ON ENJOY OUR SHOW.
RACHEL: YEAH.
WELL, THE WHOLE DAY WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE YOU, "THE FIVE,"